[موسيقى]
الارجنتين تواجه كرواتيا في اولى مباريات
المربع الذهبي فرنسا تشعر بالحذر وتستعد
لضجيج الجماهير المغربيه
على العربيه
بين منتخب الارجنتين وكرواتيا في دوري نصف
النهائي عالم ملعب روسيل
انجاز يضاف الى سجلات قائدهم ميسي المليئه
بالبطولات مع كاس العالم فيما يتطلع الكره
ايضا الى اهداء البطوله لقائد المنتخب
بين المنتخب
بثلاثه اهداف نظيفه وذلك ضمن دوري
المجموعات في مونديال روسيا 2018
نبقى في اخبار المونديال حيث ستخدوا فرنسا
مباراه الناصريه ضد المغرب يوم غد
الاربعاء باقصى درجه الاحترام لخصمها
العربي مدرب منتخب الديوك قال في مؤتمر
الصحفيين المنافسه يستفيد من الدعم الكبير
هذا في معبر قائد المنتخب الفرنسيه
[موسيقى]
وبعيدا عن اخباركاس العالم والى مصر هذه
المره حيث كشف مدير عام جمارك مطار
القاهره الدولي ماجد موسى عن كميه الذهب
والدولارات المسموح بدخولها عبر المطارات
حتى لا يقع الراكب تحت طائله القانون
وسقاله في تصريحات لبرنامج الحكايات على
ام بي سي مصر ان القانون يعطي للراكب سواء
المصري او الاجنبي مسموحات بقيمه 10,000
دولار وما يقابلها بالعملات الاخرى مضيفا
انه لا يوجد شيء يتم مصادرته من قبل
الجمارك ولكن يتم التحفظ عليه في الوداع
بالمطار
ودفعي قيمه التسامح
و في حادثه واسعه قدمه وزاره الخارجيه
النرويجيه بطلب من اداره الدعم الخاصه من
خلال حسابي الرسمي بسبب تعريف الوزاره
حكوميه تابعه لنيجيريا في تغريده الخارجيه
النرويجيه الاعزاء في دعمته
استمتع بالعلاقات الثنائيه والتقارب في
الحروف الابجديه مع نيجيريا سنكون ممتنين
اذا تم تعريفنا باننا ان نرويج وذلك ما
اضافه وجه مبتسم في ما لم يرد اي تعليق من
المنصه الزرقاء على هذه التغريده التي
انتشرت بشكل واسع
وفي خبرنا الاخير تطرح دار للمزادات في
الولايات المتحده الخاصه بكائن الفضائي في
فيلم للبيع بعد 40 عاما على انتاج الفيلم
ودار طرحت الدنيا مقابله سعر التقديريه
راح بين مليون وثلاثه ملايين دولار كما
تمثل الدميه الصغيره ذات الاطار المصنوع
من الكاميرات تحفه هندسيه صغيره تتالف من
85 مفصلا الميكانيكيا وهو ما يكفي لضخل
حياته بهذا المخلوق الفضائي الذي اثرت قصه
صداقه مع شخصيه الطفل العالم باسره
[موسيقى]